all right we're going to talk about 10
different signs that you're afraid to
lead not whether you're ready to lead or
not because you're never fully going to
be ready but 10 signs that you're
actually afraid of leaders
[Music]
okay so fear number one you are afraid
of making a decision that the sole
responsibility could end up being on you
so you're always wishy-washy with a
decision God forbid if it's your
decision that possibly goes wrong here's
the reality of it as a leader the shot
caller you have to call shots it doesn't
mean all your shots are going to be good
or bad but your team's gonna respect the
fact that you call the shot you executed
and you took the responsibility and
you're okay with that eventually your
percentage of making better decisions
will go higher but if you're afraid of
actually calling the shot and your
decisions could be a bad decision you're
always afraid of that you're never going
to be leading a big crowd sign number
two you you tell a different story
meaning you spin the story a little bit
of what actually happens so for example
your boss is going to ask you your CEO
is going to ask you yeah we need you to
go do XYZ gonna have this conversation
with the client or this employee that's
reporting to you or this vendor or this
partner and you go in and you don't say
anything that you were supposed to do
and you actually took the side of the
vendor or the customer you're like yeah
I agree with well you know how it is
sometimes when you're dealing with them
they're kind of tough to work with trust
me I see it as well myself you know so I
understand why you guys are so upset I'm
also upset sometimes when I deal with
them and you're not the only person
other people are also upset but let me
go back to talk to them then you come
and you say so let me tell you what I
told them I told them this and I said if
you don't do this we may not do business
with you oh wow what an impressive you
know person that you're going out there
but you spun the story because you were
worried of having the real conversation
and you're like the guy that said I went
in there I got into a fight dad you'd be
so proud but that's not what happened
you got a black eye and you came back
and they won and you lost because you
were afraid of actually telling the real
story so the person you're reporting to
can give you feedback so you can improve
a sign that you're afraid to lead sign
number three you are too concerned to
please everybody in your life let me
explain so to me in business
relationships you have three different
Dynamics okay you have a dynamic of
those above you you have the dynamic of
people at the same level as you and you
have the dynamic of people below you
that report to you too often people that
are too concerned about pleasing
everybody they are good with the people
that report to them they're good with
co-workers but they're not good up here
and that's a sign that you're never
going to end up being here because you
don't have the understanding of what
these guys are at so rather than saying
well you know if there's a score we all
please people by the way I want to
please you you want to please me you
want to please your wife your husband
your parents your kids everybody but if
the goal is to please 100 of the time
you're not a leader those relationship
Dynamics are different sometimes instead
of saying well yeah you know what you
you really didn't do your thing this is
the seventh time you were late you're
always late everybody in the company
knows you have a reputation for being
late you keep saying you're gonna
improved there and you don't versus wink
wink don't worry about it I know you
live you live far from here you're
always late I got your back don't worry
about it you just undermine the person
that is saying we got to raise the
standards hey the budget look you've
gone above the budget by 73 000 this was
your budget hey don't worry about it I
got this listen everybody's above budget
and no one's hitting their budget
numbers don't worry about it we think
it's going to be okay that's kind of
like stealing money from the company
because you're not you're afraid of
telling people get your budget together
or your co-workers oh hey how you doing
man everything good you know everything
good oh yeah man he's tough to work with
her she's tough to work with instead of
saying hey they're bitching about the
boss and you are the leader and you say
I'm sorry man I don't feel the way you
do I think that guy's got a very hard
job and a hard responsibility to be him
is a lot of pressure I don't want his
job and he's doing his best and I think
we've got to have his back a little bit
more quite frankly you don't have his
back all the time you're not that person
because you want everybody as your
co-workers to like you that's a sign
you're afraid of leading Point number
four this one's gonna be tough you ready
when his shoes are your responsibility
say you got five direct reports or five
customers or five projects you're
managing three projects you're managing
and a conflict comes out rather than it
getting stuck right there or it getting
addressed with you and no longer coming
up again you create work for four other
people meaning yeah well listen you know
uh Patrick said no this is on Patrick's
calling it's not my call it's his call
oh because those people said no or these
people said no so now that customer is
going to say let me talk to this person
let me talk to that person let me talk
to this person your job of handling that
you could squashed it right there you
just got three additional people that
have to do a 90 minute Zoom with that
same individual and you cost a lot of
money for the company and a waste of
time because you're afraid to leave and
manage that issue and Lead it right
there we have a person in the company my
insurance company ticket back in I want
to give him a quick shout out this guy
is extremely good at leading and
processing the issue there so it never
rolls up and it gets solved not like
it's kind of like brushed aside and oh
so you are you complaining no he
addresses it they process it and he
handles it and it doesn't roll up to me
it used to be a time 10 years ago where
seven out of 10 would roll up to me then
it went to five out of 10 then 3 out of
ten now it's one out of ten because
that's a crisis and I have to be a part
of it but that's a sign of somebody that
is not afraid of leading because he
processed the issue right there and it's
addressed and we move on another sign
you're afraid of leading you want to
take credit for all the great ideas or
the work that people on your team do to
you and then you say well I came up with
that I came up with this we had a person
that we were working with many many
years ago he would come to meetings and
he would present an idea and I'm like oh
my God those three ideas who came up
with these ideas he says oh I came up
with all these ideas myself I'm like
that's freaking incredible so every week
he's coming out with these ideas
wow this is sick this guy's a solid guy
let me tell you what happened all of a
sudden one of the guys one of the ideas
I said no to I'm walking out and one of
our employees comes and say Pat can I
ask you a question yeah one of the ideas
I put a lot of time into and I heard you
rejected the idea I want to find out why
I'm like What's that the idea was about
that I'm not going to say the idea
because this is the idea I'm like that
was your idea yeah
okay good idea let me think about it I
didn't throw the other guy under the bus
but I kept it here two weeks later
another person told me about an idea
that I gave to this person so one day I
had to meet him because I'm not afraid
of conflict I addressed it with this
person I think a question for you who
came up with that idea I came up with
the idea who came up with this idea I
came up with the idea you sure Johnny
didn't come up with the idea
you sure the other one Larry didn't come
up with the idea so I'm curious why do
you take credit for the ideas that
others came up with what's the you
realize that's a sign of a person that's
not ready to be a leader you can give
credit it's not like you're going to get
in trouble if somebody's a true leader
they'll say something like let me tell
you Larry came up with an incredible
idea that I think we ought to consider
he said
what do you think about this I think
it's a greater wow that's good now I
know how humble you are how confident
you are how comfortable you are in your
own skin you're ready to lead at the
next level because you're about building
people that's very hard to find so this
next one it's a fear to lead you know
what it is deflecting blame rather than
saying you know what this was on me I
screwed up here this this was our fault
no it was that person's fault it was
this person's fault you know what my
favorite is it's the equipment's fault
the equipment can't do nothing about it
it's the equipment's fault so now what
do I need to do call the equipment and
chew out the equipment hey Mr equipment
shame on you for what you did I can't
talk to the equipment someone has to
take responsibility none of us like to
take the blame because it's not an
exciting thing to say but you know who
takes responsibility and moves on
leaders pick responsibility and improve
remember none of us like it and we've
all been in a position where we didn't
want to take it and both you and I know
that's not a sign of a leader so if you
don't do that it's another sign you fear
leading by not taking full
responsibility next fear this is an
obvious one I already talked about it
earlier fear of conflict you need to
have a very high level conversation with
somebody you delay for one day you delay
for two days you delay for three days
four days five days one we lost decline
there needs to be a high level
conversation of conflict with somebody
clients you know they're not happy with
this thing they don't understand a
product okay I want to call him I'm
going to call him I'll call him tomorrow
I'll call him the next day to cancel you
have an issue with a partner with a
vendor you have to have a conversation
with somebody that keeps doing the same
thing over and over again expenses costs
late not hitting their deadline not
finishing their project making comments
at work that you've told them to stop
doing that any of this stuff they keep
doing it you just don't want to address
it with them because you're worried I've
ran a sales team for a long time hygiene
we had people in our office that had
hygiene issues nobody wanted to have the
conversation you know what was one of
the ways that I always engaged if
somebody was a leader the person that
knew how to have the conversation and do
it in a proper way which is my next
point I always knew that person was
somebody that could eventually be a
leader and everybody else I was like can
you go tell them he smells can you go
tell them can you go tell them can you
go tell him I got this couple people
they would come in it was an art one
what a weird way to gain somebody is
ready to be a leader because hey Johnny
can I talk to you yeah Johnny you know
everyone loves you here yes can I be
honest with you yes so I'm comfortable
you're okay with this yes you sure I
have your permission yes how often do
you brush your teeth what do you mean my
breath smells yes it does and I'm only
telling you this because when it comes
down to sales if a customer has to smell
something they're going to figure out a
way to cancel deployment as much as
possible and your closing ratio needs a
little bit of help and we've heard from
some people how often you shower what do
you use what stick do you use what do
you use with this what do you use with
and then we bring a gift so here's what
I use first one is on me second one is
on you can we kind of work on this
together you and I and we keep this our
little project to work on yes fantastic
awesome great then obviously I'm giving
you like a faster version of how it
actually takes place next thing you know
the next day you know that person if you
do it in a gentle way that person comes
to you and says hey just to let you know
how do I smell and it was always funny
I'm like like dude you smell good I said
look watch this like dude you smell good
dog let's go close some dude that's
awesome that person is ready to lead
because they're able to have difficult
conversations so some of you are
watching this saying you know what I got
seven people that smell bad I'm gonna go
talk to them today the point is stop
being afraid of having conversations
that could lead to a conflict leaders
are not afraid the next one a fear that
many have you ready you know why people
fear having a conflict because they
think it's going to get ugly and it's
going to get nasty and it's going to get
screaming all this other stuff the only
reason that should happen is because of
one thing and that's the approach we're
at the Cigar Lounge the other day at the
boardroom we finished up the cigar we're
having our first cigar we're breaking
we're having a great conversation at
night one of the players absolute stud
of a guy Haas says which topic should
you avoid bringing up when you're
working with people any subjects that
you avoid I said you know it's crazy
we're always been told don't talk about
religion politics all this other stuff I
said I never followed that philosophy
because I'm interested in those things
and I want to know what people think
because I don't have all the truth and I
want to learn from people I said what I
learned over the years the problem isn't
the subject the problem is the approach
in which you address the subject let me
give a perfect scene of a movie for you
there's a movie called The Roadhouse
Roadhouse the movie by one of my
favorite actors of all time Patrick
Swayze there is a singing in the scene
he's talking to all the security guards
that they're running this bar and it's
one of those old acting that was like
it's a it's such a like a fake acting
but anyways it's like fun to watch a
great I watched this in so many times in
the Army and they're asking a question
he says you asked them to leave but be
nice instead of me doing the acting just
watch this short clip here somebody gets
in your face and calls you a [__]
I want you to be nice
okay
ask him to walk
be nice if you won't walk walk him but
be nice if you can't walk him one of the
others will help you and you'll both be
nice very simple concept address the
conflict but be nice and respectful
address the issue but be nice that's how
simple it is the only reason you fear
conflict is because you're not being
nice with your approach so Point number
nine is something all of us can work on
all of us to ask before you soon so it's
to be understanding only way you can be
understanding is by asking questions of
what's going on sometimes we don't have
full context sometimes we don't know
what's going on that person's personal
life or their life or what they are
dealing with this is why having a
relationship with the individual is a
good thing and asking questions how are
things how you doing what's going on
what do you have with this what are you
at with that and then they'll tell you
and they say I've noticed certain Trends
lately that the numbers and the
performance and the way you've been
behaving is not what's typically matches
what your common consistent trend has
something changed yeah let me explain to
what's going on what's that and they're
going to open I'm going through a
difficult time my marriage my mom is
sick I'm going through it it's something
I'm going through it's really tough no
problem so show understanding and they
say I totally understand that you're
going through this I'm so sorry you're
going through this at the same time we
have a business to run and it's
challenging what level of expectation
can I have from you moving forward
during this season of your life Pat
trust me I'm going to get back to what
I'm doing okay great or Pat I don't know
hey how about we do this do you want to
take the next two days off go spend time
with your family can I do that go take
PTO do your thing spend time with your
family but when we come back on Monday I
want your best you have no idea how much
I appreciate that's great no problem
that's the part about having the
conversation as long as you're asking
what they're going through it is our job
to be understanding and if you do that
you don't have to fear conflict last
point I'll make it for you easy not
gonna be long on this everything is
about you all the decisions you make is
how it benefits you if you're a leader
the decisions have to be made with how
it benefits the organization first venue
it's a team over me mentality company
over me mentality when you're running a
company who has to get the checks first
who has to get paid first your
Supporting Cast your team I didn't get
paid for a long time when we started the
insurance company and every month my
savings were depleting because I need to
make sure my staff was getting paid
because they trusted my vision it had to
be them first before me I'm not telling
you if you're an employee or executive
or director you should not get paid
someone I'm saying to you all I'm saying
to you is when you're leading your team
think about what's in the best interest
of the company of the team of the vision
venue lead with that and if you come
from that place more people will take
your Council your direction and your
vision I got a video to recommend to you
about my oldest son watch this video he
sat right there Tico I think you want to
say something to everybody come on tell
us tell us what you're thinking I was
actually coming over here to say the
advice was good and I want to hear more
about it because it was pretty
interesting it wasn't really I didn't
even expect him to say I didn't tell him
to say this what did you learn from it
well basically yeah
conflict
is not bad as long as you deal with it
good okay when we have conflict do I
typically bring it up or do I wait a
week or two
um bring it up how often do I bring it
up fairly quickly when we have issues
together
you don't really remember so I don't
have tough conversations with you at all
okay
that's why you're a leader buddy all
good okay I got two videos I want to
recommend to you but we do respectfully
you know we do respectfully absolutely
because I
I am no I I Patrick Gabriel by David
will one day be a great leader awesome
because that's our standard anyways two
videos number one it's a video I did on
how to deal with conflict if you've
never seen this before there's eight
ways of doing it click here to watch
this video the other one is a quiz we
created on learning how to drive
different personalities and what method
works with different personalities that
you're driving including yourself if
you've never taken a quiz before click
here to take the quiz either way take
care everybody bye bye
foreign
[Music]